all right meantime let's bring in Texas
congressman Dan Crenshaw former Navy
SEAL
author of the book fortitude American
resilience in the age of outrage he
joins us from his location congressman
wanted because you are representing a
district in Texas wanted to ask you
about Shelly Luther that salon owner who
said look I got a reopen I know I can't
open right now but I got to do it
because I got to put food on the table
she was held in containers
a cease and desist order she tore it up
famously at a public demonstration and
then in from the judge the judge says
you want to apologize
she said no what sort of this I have to
disagree with you sir when I when you
say that I'm selfish because feeding my
kids is not selfish I have here silence
that are going hungry because they'd
rather feed their kids so sir if you
think the laws more important than kids
getting fed and please go ahead with
your decision but I'm not the salon
congressman it seems like what every
parent would do I mean ultimately you
need to feed your children we do know
that a GoFundMe page has been started
and over a half a million dollars has
been raised for her so far your thoughts
on this yeah you know these these
so-called leaders and these so-called
judges across the country you know
arresting moms and dads and of course
she's not the only case dad was arrested
in Colorado for playing catch with his
daughter paddleboarder who was
paddleboarding alone in the ocean was
chased down by police boats in
California guy in Florida had to be sent
to court because he was trying to sell
takeout out of his restaurant this is
happening over and over and these again
these so-called leaders these so-called
judges they need to take a civics lesson
okay these laws will not be respected if
they are not respectable laws people are
not dumb they can understand and they
can they can assess whether a law makes
sense whether it's really based on data
and public health and a lot of these
things aren't right we've seen a lot of
rules being passed that simply don't
make sense and then it goes and then
they go further
then they want to actually punish you
they want to use the full force of the
law fine you throw you in jail arrest
you take away your freedom just because
you're engaging in activity that was
previously perfectly legal
okay engaging in a voluntary transaction
with another human being has long been a
legal and perfectly okay activity and to
all of a sudden make it illegal and then
use the full force of the law to enforce
it
that goes against our very basic values
listen I'm all for the guidelines okay
but the lot but the government has to
use the lightest touch possible and
these so called leaders are not doing
that they are they're infringing on
people's freedoms all while by the way
advocating to allow other criminals who
have previously been in jail to be
released so it's contradictory in that
sense to and it's in it's in complete
contradiction to our Constitution and
our way of life and what our society is
founded upon I mean I'll give you an
example why can't you go to a car wash
why can't a jewelry store open up on
Mother's Day evidently for in order to
maybe sustain their business why can the
liquor store be open and why can I go to
a supermarket but I can't go to a sports
store why do they expect people to
really think that's rationalized
behavior why do they think I can't walk
on the beach or get this sit on the
beach how dare I sit on the beach I
could get a fine if I sit and sunbathe
on the beach as opposed to sit on my
couch where 66% of the people who have
been hospitalized in New York where
people who are sheltered in place Dan
we're never drunk on power this is not
working on power they think we're stupid
they think we're stupid and they're
drunk on power and this is why you're
seeing people rise up Americans are sick
of it they have a sense of injustice
they have a sense that these again these
so-called leaders these so-called judges
they they have a sense that they're not
actually implementing the law because
these aren't laws right these are
executive orders they have a sense that
they're not really implementing justice
as we understand it as a culture and as
a society we know that they're doing the
wrong thing and we have to call them out
for it
okay so Dan or congressman under the
house is thinking about drafting a new
bill Nancy Pelosi's talked about it
being one trillion dollars to help
health care workers first responders
postal workers and teachers what are the
Republicans think about this and how
much do you think this will there be
another relief bill and how much listen
first of all the way we need to assess
future relief bills is one problem at a
time with one solution at a time we
could have been in Congress and in the
house working this whole time Nancy
Pelosi wants the American people who
believe that we're only allowed to go
and work once every three weeks and pass
multi trillion dollar bills okay so so
here's their playbook they want you to
stay locked down all right and they'll
arrest you if you don't abide they don't
want you to have your job anymore they
want their they want to wait for these
industries to fail so there's no jobs to
go back to and then they want to act
like these benevolent rulers and offer
you money well whose money is that it's
your money and it's especially your kids
money because one day that has to be
paid back and it's gonna be your kids
taxes that have to be raised okay and
then in 2020 in the twenty twenty
elections the Democrats are gonna come
back and say look how generous we were
with your money that's their playbook
and we have to wake up to this this is
not responsible governance there isn't
some unlimited amount of money to be
spending especially to bail out states
that have been terrible with their with
their fiscal responsibility this entire
time okay if you're a member of Congress
from Texas I don't see how you want to
use Texan federal tax dollars that we're
paying to bail out other states that
have been totally irresponsible with
their finances all of this time that's
the kind of stuff that's being that's
going to be put into this it's gonna be
enormous it's not how we should be
governing it has to be discrete
solutions for discrete problems that
would be the responsible thing to do
honest debate in the house that's what
we should be doing we have taken
perfectly safe measures in order to do
that congressmen speaking of responsible
a lot of people have been wondering were
responsible things being done behind the
scenes that the Department of Justice
and the FBI to forward the Russia
investigation and ultimately we found
out a little more yesterday when the
Department of Justice released once
again a redacted version of one of the
scope memos that rod Rosen
sign had given to Robert Mahler
regarding what he could look to and
among other things part of the scope
memo from August 2nd 2017 said look for
any links and/or coordination between
the Russian government and individuals
associated with the campaign of
President Donald Trump and secondly any
matters that arose or may arise directly
from that investigation there were four
names on it
Carter page Paul Manafort George
papadopolis and Michael Flynn and to a
lot of people they wanted to know what
the scope was you know how broad was his
authority it seems like it was quite
broad because some things panned out and
a lot of stuff did not right and here's
the best way to summarize what's
actually going on here this was an
investigation in search of a crime and
that should terrify Americans and the
more we find out about this entire probe
that this entire narrative that was spun
for years tricking the American people
into thinking that their president was
some Russian puppet what were they
really doing they had an idea they had a
conclusion they had a crime that they
wanted to prove and they gave themselves
the power to try and prove it this is
this is a horrible horrible precedent to
set okay it goes against again every
foundation we have in jurisprudence and
law and due process but this is what
they were doing and it's added on top of
the the FISA the FISA warrant abuse its
added on top of what we just found out
about general Flynn and how the FBI
tried to ambush him you know it's it's
it's it's added on top of what we now
know about the steel dossier and how
that was actually used as supposed
evidence to to investigate these
supposed crimes it should really
terrifying xand and I hope more people
realize this member you were you were
dragged by the media through this crazy
narrative this crazy rollercoaster for
years and it was all house of cards
none of it it turns out none of it was
true and who did this it was all
politically biased it was all
confirmation biased from these DOJ
officials from the Obama administration
because they hated Trump so badly and
they and they thought that they they
thought that they that they were
exerting some kind of justice against
this man but
the end they were the ones breaking the
law and breaking our trust and Danny and
reading your book fortitude you talk
about the band of brothers the way you
guys look out for each other and I'm
wondering how you feel about the FBI
sticking together we see in this
terrible behavior we're hearing behind
the scenes the FBI is embarrassed by it
McCabe and struck in Page and call me
the way they acted from the 7th floor as
opposed to the the way that's really
running the bureau's why haven't there
been FBI whistleblowers do you think and
there's a go to the same mindset that
you guys have in the Special Forces yeah
I don't know you know I've never been
part of the FBI do you know a lot of FBI
agents that are really really great
people so I want to give them the
benefit of the doubt just like in the
SEAL Teams sometimes we get bad apples
and they embarrass the entire community
the best thing you can do in that case
is disown the bad apples because in the
end you have to protect the integrity of
the institution the FBI is an
institution yes I know the wet bi up
said the FBI they should be I mean they
should I mean I agree with I'm agreeing
with you I should be and I just I wish I
could tell you more I just can't I think
I think they need I think they need to
man up and actually and actually get rid
of some of these bad actors who have
clearly shown political bias and clearly
shown confirmation bias and and and and
completely thrown away due process and
rule of law in order to do it yeah all
right congressman thank you for being
here
no thank you thanks for having me you're
welcome you're welcome